だからコロナは不気味なんで
これが中継ですか  緩んでるから
撮ります？どうぞ  はい
ありがとうございます
おめでとうございます
すごい ちょっと一瞬 一瞬今だけ
いやもう全部見てください
あと講義終わってからちょっとご案内もできると思います
許可取ったので はい  なので何からスタートしなきゃいけないから
何やるか言わないと難しいという状況がありますね
はい っていう話で いいよ
大丈夫 稲田さん ハイハイしてるから
はいはい わかりました
北野さんもう見れちゃった
シャワーある どうですか？ゆっくりゆっくり
ゆっくり  すごいしょ すごいしょ
要するにお風呂の組み入れじゃないから
シャワーの組み入れだから
ちゃんとホテルみたいだから
これあれか ねえねえねえ
これ  スマホございます？今ライブもう始まっちゃったんですよ
今川本さんに写ってましたって
今でいい  今 えーとえーと公式チャンネル見てライブ
ライブを見てください
わからない  え？いや 公式チャンネル YOUTUBE
YOUTUBE  YOUTUBE
はい 業界の公式チャンネル
少し休憩します あ これですね
これが画面で今多分映ってますよ
これが画面なんで タイムラグある？ うん
角度ちょっと変えていただいて
後から来たやつ ここでやんなきゃいけないの
はい  高さがもうちょっと
高さがね 上が変えらんないんですよね
もうちょっと指示が こんなにがっつり固めなくてもいいんじゃないかな
これ以上は怖い  怖い？ あの
そう やっぱ傾いちゃう
川本さんの画面を見ながらちょっと補正をして
ごめんなさい あの 思い描いてくる人
高さはちょうどそれになって
三秒 三秒とか五秒とかすればいい
まあそれはインターネットの世界につながってる
うちだけを使ってやって
お釈迦様は絶対映らないですね
まあここがメインで  こんな感じかな
どうですか？ 素晴らしいじゃないですか
いい？ いいよ すごくいい
こんな綺麗に映るとは
すごい なんかやったの？何ですか？すごいじゃない
お釈迦様がギリギリ入る
入りますね これね  お釈迦様
お釈迦様入ります  こちらの方
カチカチに固めてください
カチカチに 頭どうぞ  どちら？ あ
タッチお願いします 大丈夫ですよ
はい 当社のタッチをお願いします
お願いします  うん すごくいい
僕はこれ まだまだ下ろさなくて大丈夫です
下ろせるよ  あ ここに置けばいい？じゃあ
在京僧のくじらせてもらった
ガタガタしないように
あ ちょっと失礼します
とりあえずとりあえず
あと戻って だいぶずれます
だいぶずれます  でもすごい
そうですよね  全員映ってるよこれ
素晴らしいですね 渡辺さん
いいじゃないですか スマホがいる
APPLEが開いてます
全然画角足んないなと思ったんだけど
万事足る 変えました？イベントのあれ
超広角があるから  いやでもビデオだと使えないかなと
画角変えた？ 変えない
変えない？俺欲しいな
このぐらいの部屋は入るよ
ちょっと高くした方が
もうライブ配信始まってますので映りますよ
会長 これはいつのタイミングですか？ こう出てから二時半
二時半  十時半 一緒に  ブッダプージャの始まる前に？ ブッダプージャ
あ プログラムここあります？ブッダプージャ後ですね
後ですね はい  お願いします
今日の品物のプレゼント
ここのところですね  あの物品
あの僕個人で それね あの放送があるので
アナウンスがあるので
あのひとり動かないことになりますので
あの「駐車場に来てください」って言われると思います
はい はい これを預かってるばかりで
あそこに置いてあるのは教会のものとお預かりしているもの
全部ですか？ 全部 はい
参加して これは持った方がいいですよ
これは持った方がいい
お坊さんの時にも意味ありますから
お水ですよね  お湯です
はい  雨じゃなくてよかったですね
ちょっとでも  久米田さん
あれですね ここに今あれですからね
あれを食事が終わったらですね
皆さん終わって お坊さん終わったら
我々がですね セッティングをしてきます
男手で 椅子を持ってきたりと
素晴らしい景色の そうですね
じゃあこれで [背景の雑音]お坊様とお釈迦様が先だから一回出ます
全員  あの 須賀さん  はい
いないいない  私にも何かちょっと高くて五千円だから
はい  こちらに何か  あ まだありますよ
三枚あります  三枚ぐらい
村松社長そこに座るんですか？ こちらでいいです
一番端で わかりました
じゃあ今こうやって置きます
難しい 足  座った  はいはい
なんだった？ ココナッツミルク
ココナッツミルク ココナッツミルク
ココナッツミルク はい
わかりました  村田さんは？ 今黒田君に聞かれたんで
はいはいはい 村田社長
それで張りますか？三枚しかないと
はい それで  はい  二層になるんですね
あの 座れるんですよ すごい
今日はここでお布施をして
はい ありがとうございます
心配するほどなかったですね
いっぱいですね やばいいっぱい
あの黄色いちょっと  そうですね
あれが  すごい  はい よかったですね
えー本当 うん  近くに  そうそうそう
近くてね あー斜め撮りたかったけど
撮ろうか私一枚 違う違う違う違う
あのおねりとか撮りたくなりそうだけど
まあいいや もう素敵 とりあえず今それ持っているとさ
あの意外と私なんかあれがバッグが邪魔になりそうで
ダメちゃんあとで共有して
ダメちゃん出るぞ  そうですね
追加分です  はい ありがとうございます
はい  なんか情報がそんなに [笑い]
[雑音][雑音][話し声][背景の雑音]適当に進んで座ってください
南無タッサ ヴァラワト アラーハト サммаサムブッダッサ
南無タッサ ヴァラワト アラーハト サemmaサンブッダッサ
南無タッサ ヴァラワト アラーハト サammaサムブッダッサ
仏ダンシャランガミ  仏ダンシャランガチャミ
ダンマンシャランガチャミー
ダンマンシャランガチャーミ
シャンガンシャランガっちゃーみい
サンガンスラナンガジャミー
ドゥティアンピ ブッダンスラナムガッチャーミー
ドゥティアンピーウッタサラナムガッチャン
ドゥティあんぴぃダンマಂシャラナンがっちゃんいい
ドゥティア mpi ダンマウンサラナムガッチャーミー
ドゥティヤンピーサンガングシュラナムガチャアミー
ドゥティアmp Sangam スラナムガッチャミー
パティヤマピー豚装具シャラムガッジャーニー
パティヤンプリフッドダメサラナムガッチャームー
Pati ヤンフィダンマンシャラナムカッチアーニ
Yamp данman サラナムガッチャームー
Saty やんぴi サンガムサロン намガッチャミー
Saty アンキーサンガムスラナムガッチャムー
アナータパーターウェーラマニ シッカPadang サマーディヤーミー
Adinna ダナーウェーラマニ シッカー Padang サマーディーヤーミー
アドインナーダーナ・ヴェーラマニ シッターファランサマーディアミー
Kamesu ミッシャーサーラーウェーラマニ シッカーPadaN サマーディヤーミー
Kamesu ミッチャーサーラーウェーラマニ シックーパーランサマーディアミー
Missaワーザーヴェーラマニシッカ PadaN サマーディヤーミー
Missa ワードだヴェーラマニ シッカーファランサマーデリアーミー
Surā Meraya Majjapamādaṭṭhānāเวーラマニ シッカー padaM サマーディーヤミー
Meraya マージャパンまだっだなヴェーラマニ シッカpadam サマーディーヤミー
[鐘の音]懺悔いたします
世の闇に覆われて身口意の三業によって犯してしまった過ちがあります
佛法僧に対する過ち 恩師に対する過ち
生きてし得るものに対する過ち
これら一切の過ちを懺悔致します
また自分が負せた他の人々の過ちも許します
このように雑事を離れ
一人静かに自己の心身を得を持ってみつめる時
瞬間瞬間変化消滅続ける現象ヴィパッサナーによって洞察し
真の幸福を得て解脱の道へ導かれますようにとここに誓願をいたしました 【
読経】 Svākkhāto bhagavatadhammo sanvittiko akaṇakaṇo ehi passiko.[鐘の音][経典]この度
この度 いよいよに三十歩という非常に近いところに新たな僧房を建てることはできました
これまでお坊様に集まっていただくにも
僧房が足りないということが非常に大きな我々の課題でございましたけれども
この度 このような立派な僧房をお寄せさせていただけることを大変ありがたく思っております
よろしくお願いいたします
四方聖なる大山河に行う
はい はい はい 四方聖なる大山河に行うお布施の宣言書
宗教法人日本テーラワーダ仏教協会に住む仏弟子が
三宝への尊信とともに
日本に釈尊の真の教えが根付くことを真心より願い
東京都渋谷区幡ヶ谷一の二の二十二の二十二十家比丘サンガに使用していただく僧房を
建立しましたことを無上の喜びとともに報告いたします
この僧坊を既に来られた
またこれから来られる仏弟子
聖なる四方比丘サンガにお布施いたします
サダーフサダーフサダーフ
ナモー タッサ ヴァラト アラハト サмма サムブッダッサ
はい 皆さん 今抜けてる人は聞いてください
これから  はい  イマン アラマン アラタ ナガタッサ サートゥ ビサッサ ビクサンガッサ デーワ
イマン アラマン アラタ ナガタッサ サートゥ ビサッサ ビクサンガッサ デーワ
この僧坊を既に来られた
またこれから来られる仏弟子
聖なる四方比丘サンガにお布施いたします
この この功徳により 我々は
この部分もう一回言って
はい この僧坊を既に来られた
またこれから来られる仏弟子
聖なる四方比丘サンガにお布施いたします
この僧坊を既に来られた
またこれから来られる仏弟子
聖なる四方比丘サンガにお布施いたします
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
イダンメ プンニャン アサヴァッカヤワハン ホトゥ
この功徳により 我々は涅槃へと導かれることを
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
この僧房の鍵になります
はい ナモー タッサ バガワト アラハト サмма サムブッダッサ
ナモー タッサ バガワト アラハト サмма サムブッダッサ
サブゲ パパ サッカラナグサラ サワサン パダ サチッタ パリジョタナム エタム ブッダナ サーサナカンティ パラ
マンタ ポティティッカ ニッバーナ パラマン パダンティ ブッダナ
ナイ パッパジト パルーパダーティ サマノ ホティ パランディエ タヤント アノカバート アノカバート パティモッ
ペッチャ サンガルーマ カンニュタチャ パッタスミ
パンタンチャ サヤナ サナン アティチッテチャ アヨローエタム ブッダナ サーサナ
エーテーワ サッチャ バッジェナ タジュサン ガタナッタヤン エタム
[仏教経典]サティサティサティ
で やっぱりあの修行僧の僧房建築という
お釈迦様の方式を取りました
で あの僧房というかね
そのところですね まあ提供するってことはお釈迦様の時代からあったことで
あまりこの土地を施述って話は聞いたことはないんだけどね
でもまあ 土地の上でなければ建物も建てませんけどね
大体そのところですね
修行僧が施するの これスリランカ仏教ではたくさん土地を施することにあの改良したんです
だからやっぱり地主が豪快にいるんです
その大概の政府が泥棒して盗んでいるんです
法律的に政府に回収することじゃなくてね
まあそれはそれで私に関係ない
それでまあとにかくあの僧房というのは
まあ僧房はずっとあるわけじゃないんだからね
移転しますからね 土地はそういうものじゃないんですね
だから私の言ってる意味では
土地を施述ということはなかったな
あります  あってあるのはいいんだけどね
土地の施はちょっとそういうところはこれはもう土地が残るんだからね
サンガの財産であることはもうずっとこれ解消できない
だからまずいんです だから
建物みたいな無常なものを入れたら
それが壊れたら まあサンガの財産としても消えなかったからね
えーとですね それからまあこういう建物に
建物にね 皆様が何か持ってきたら
儀式ではなくても お布施として置いておけば
まあお子さんがいたらちょっと手渡しておけば
それもサンガのお布施になります
あの あまり儀式がいらない
なぜかというと 椅子やらテーブルやらベッドやらね
そういう家具 家に関わる家具は個人的に受けることはしないんです
受けられないんです だから一旦建物をお布施したら
誰かが電気を勝手に来て変えたりする
それもサンガにお布施したことになります
儀式がなくてもね うーん
こんなこと言っちゃうと面倒くさくなる可能性あります
どうせ頭どう働こうがと思う
知ってます まあ誰かがね
まあ掃除機を買ってきて置いておけば
まあ手渡ししてもなくてもここで座ってくださいと
それはもうサンガのお布施なんです
だからまあそこはもう最初にかこれをやっておけば
まあそれでまあどうにでも
だからシーシャータオルやらこのこの場所で使うものね
食事だけですね 食事はその時儀式を行わなくちゃいけないんです
食事は個人所有するものだからね
他の個人的に所有するものじゃない
で まあそれはね あんな仏教徒がなんて喜んでやるのはね
やっぱりこのずーっとなんかすごい大きな会社投資したような感じでね
すごい立派なこの家具を買ったような感じで
ずーっと 買ったら ずっと功徳がね
入るんですね だから死後でもね
あの天界やらそういうところに生まれたら思い出しますからね
私は人間の時こんなことを思って
それでもその場所はまだ生きているから
それでも本人に あの功徳が増えてくれているんですね
だからそういう投資目的で昔
[笑い]提供 [笑い][咳]まあ冗談はあのこにして
一応あの仏陀の真理に教えに従ってなんかあると
まあそういうことになります
自慢してはいけないっていうのは当たり前にね
決して自慢してはいけない
しかし 自分が行った善行為をずっと思い出してくださいと
他人にも言ってくださいと
それだけは あの自慢という単語はその時合わない
適切じゃないんだけど
それだけ自慢してほしいんですよ
だから あの 時々私は毎日三時間瞑想と書いて
なんか自我が入って あの
これとると功徳ではなくなっちゃうんですね
自分の喜びを表すんです 「
私は人間として生まれてよかったなと思いますよ」とね 「
これくらいの良いことをできました」と 「
これぐらいの良い助けはできました」と
まあ法曹に達して これくらいのことをできる機会があって
本当に幸せだというところ
自分の喜びを相手に表す
そうすると相手も  同意
同感すれば そいつの人にも功徳になるし
まあ腹が立ったらそれはその人の収穫だからね
[笑い]馬鹿にしたらその人の
それは気にする必要はないんです 「
お前アホじゃないか」と 「
ああ すいませんですね」って言っちゃえば
それで自分がセーフで
向こうは自分の行為の結果が自然法則で
それは誰だって自分の行為の結果得てるんだからね
まあそういうことで あの
この善行為をしたことは
まあ度々思い出したり
度々この喜びを感じてみたりすることで
この無量の功徳になる
あの善行為のリストの中に
まあこれは入っている一つなんですね
で そういうことで この心の喜びってどうやって生まれるかというと
この離れたことで喜びが生まれるんです
遠いだけ見なければいけないんです
で こういうことで何を見せているかというと
自分の所有権 私が私の所有権から離れるんです
サンガに置いたらもう離れるところか
後でクレームすることもできないんです
友達に何かあげたらね
後であんたなんであそこ壊してやだと言えますか？最低文句でも言うんだからね
私から散々いろいろものをもらってお世話になってたくせに 「
あの野郎は今はこんなもんや」とかね
だから完全離れてないんですね
子供にあげるものやら友達にあげるものやら
完全なんていない だから三界に動けるっていうことはもうリクレンできません
ということは この私たちも三界
比丘たちにも権利ないんです
我々たくさん戒律ありますよ
三界の際 使う場合はこういう
こういう こういう条件の中で借りて使うということは絶対忘れないで使いなさい
ですから  買って使うんだけど
貸主っていうのはもうないんですね
法ですからね 個人じゃないんです
そういうことで この離れたことは永久的に離れたんですね
もうまたリクレンできません
宇宙空間に何か捨てたような感じ
宇宙空間にエネルギーって何か捨てちゃうと
それがどこまで行くかわからんでしょ
そういうわけで このような功徳もずっとまあ拡大して広げて
増えて増えて増えて増えていく功徳になります
それで喜び感じてください
喜びはこの離れた喜びなんですね
それが純粋な本物の喜び
だからこのクアンタム世界で僕もクアンタム心理学で教えたんだからね
だから心のエネルギーがすっごく縛られて小さくなるんですね
物質に依存すると だから物質も心が作ったものでしょうし
自分で作って自分でそれに縛されちゃいますね
だから離れると安らぎを感じる
離れた喜びを感じる それでやがて心が「なんでこんな私は客観世界作るんでしょうか」と
やめちゃったっていうところで
完全な安穏というのは成り立つんですよ
それで年収に議論もないんだだから
個人的に個性として何か年収することは無いんですね
そういうことで離れることが喜びということも理解して
この功徳によって心が清らかになりますように
解脱を達することはできますようにと
満たすることはできますようにと
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
それから この教会のメンバーたちの皆様の智慧と祝福によって
そういう方々 皆様にも
教会の全ての会員様方
我々の説法やら講演会などに参加する方々
皆様方の亡くなられた全ての親族の方々にこの功徳が入りますように
幸福に達しますように
涅槃に達することができましょう
三回 サードゥ  サードゥ
サードゥ サードゥ  それからブッダの教えを守る神々にも
この功徳をもろたぬ神々
個人個人でも守っている神々に
全ての神々にもこの功徳を授けて幸福になりますように
解脱に達することができましょうと三回
サードゥ  サードゥ サードゥ
サードゥ  ではヴィパッサナーへの道の
これを裏面の方ですね
これを読んでから合掌ということになります
はい  ナモー タッサ ヴァラワトー アラハトー サマー サムブッダッサ
ナモー タッサ ヴァラワトー アラハトー サマー サムブッダッサ
イマン ニッカン サパディッカラン ブッダハン カッサ ビクサンガッサ レーマ
イダン メ プンニャン アサワッカヤ ワハン ホトゥ
[経典]Sādhu Sādhu Sādhu
[集団唱]暗黒を破るこの灯りで
三世界の暗闇を破る灯明である釈迦牟尼如来を礼し奉る
［経典の文章］彩色宝光により麗しき
数多の御体で釈迦牟尼如来の御身を礼し奉る
［経典の文章］我はこの花もて大聖ブッダに礼し奉らん
この功徳によって解脱が得られんことを
必ずしおれ枯れるこの空華のごとく
我が肉体もまた滅びゆくものなり
［経典の文章］その御言葉は香りの結晶のごとき
無量の徳の香りをまといし
釈迦牟尼如来をこの香もて礼し奉る
［経典の文章］パーニヤメタンバガワ パティガンハートゥナヤコ
多弁にして清らかなる
また義にかないしこの飲み水を
釈迦牟尼如来に献上し奉る
世尊がお受け取りをなされますように
アディワーセトゥノーパンテー オージャナンパーリカッピタン アヌカンパンウパーダヤ パティガンハートゥムッタマム
偉大なる釈迦牟尼如来よ
我らが浄にせしこの御酒を
憐れみによって受け取られんことを願い奉る
アディワーセトゥノーパンテー サッバンサッダーヤプージタン アヌカンパンウパーダヤ パティガンハートゥムッタマム
偉大なる釈迦牟尼如来よ
我らが浄にせしその他の供物も
憐れみによって受け取られんことを願い奉る
ニベーナヤー ミサンブッダン ヴィータラーガンマハムニ ニマンタヤー ミスカタン ローカジェッタンナラーサバン
学学者 煩悩の滅人者 大聖者に食事の時をお告げし奉る
禅僧 世間上衆 四畳民を接待し奉る
カーエナワーチャチッテーナ タマデーナ マヤーカタン アッチャヤン カマメパンテー ウーリパンニャー タターガタ
大慧者たる如来に対し
我が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
カーエナワーチャチッテーナ タマデーナ マヤーカタン アッチャヤン カマメダンマ サンディッティカーカーリカ
実証できる永遠の真理たる仏法に対し
我が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
カーエナワーチャチッテーナ タマデーナ マヤーカタン アッチャヤン カマメサンガ スパティパンナアヌッタラ
無上なる正道を実践する僧団に対し
我が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
エンカーワターチャ アンゲーリ サンパタン クンニャサンパダン サンメここまで我々が積みし全ての功徳なる財宝を
神々が随喜してお受けくださいますように
あまねく全ての神々が功徳に満たされますように
ここまで我々が積みし全ての功徳なる財宝を
精霊が随喜してお受けくださいますように
あまねく全ての精霊が功徳に満たされますように
ここまで我々が積みし全ての功徳なる財宝を
一切衆生が随喜してお受けくださいますように
あまねく一切の衆生が功徳に満たされますように
この功徳が先祖に届きますように
先祖が安らぎに満たされますように
この功徳により 我々が涅槃へと導かれんことを
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
[鐘の音] ご苦労様でございます
はい [経典]そうですね
私この辺で受け取ったので差し上げますので
あのね 空中で あの 抜本して
了解です 了解です それはまだ下で
犬は持ってったのある
そして一応ここに それは向こうに持ってきたんです
戻さないで 戻さないで
これは向こうに漏れちゃったのは
まだやってないよね 一応下から来る時にする
持ってくるのね ある ね
じゃあごめんなさい それ
じゃあそこね ここに持って
ここに 私降ろす人だから
私は写真撮る人だから大変
やっぱり降ろしていいですか？そしたら置いとくね
わかるね 置いとく たまらないね
じゃあまあ いっぱいある
これあげる あ これ僕持っていきます